this is a pepper panic saga level 212
walkthrough tutorial video
I'm going to play through the  level to complete it and I'm going to explain
why I do what I do as a go
this was probably the most difficult
level in the most
recent episode pepper panic saga episode
and it can basically be impossible if
you can't remove the statues at the top
here so a lotta times if you care
make make a match appear to open this
up or you don't have anything they're
here they're concerned shockwave
you might be better off just to hit the
quit button over here and this
go ahead and start over
there are scenarios where you can you
know
makes a match is down here clear out the
statues and send shockwaves up but it's
really
difficult that way and
with 45 moves I mean you can really
spend a lot of time
in a hopeless situation which can make
you frustrated
so here I i said i have a nice set up in
here
have an L shape match and go and make
that no knock out this
in with that I'll do is well peppers the
fall into the top so that I can get the
rest the statues
okay so
you know ideally you'd want to get one
on this side too
but a you're probably not going to
get that to happen very often so
just keep in mind that you can still
complete even if this doesn't happen
you're gonna get some time is returned
if they're here but you're basically
gonna have to try to set up a shock wave
in this road right here
to get that going so
a.m. you can the you can watch these
timer
the egg over here we can imagine these
anyways these these two we can match
together but there's 1514 I'm so we
don't waste a move yet
so because if we free Expo to purple
pepper
paper in the process than those can't
wait that anyway terminal
make matches at the bottom now I'm gonna
try it really the statues
hit the statute as I go and
overall just try to set up a shock wave
in this row her column if it's a
that's really the most important thing
because if we never get real early
thirties very capable
everything else is just you're not as
important
and you know so many things will pick up
naturally as we go
or were at the statue sometimes or will
get rid of the statue all the time
so really all your focus should be on
opening up this idea
their economy the t-shaped it really
wasn't accomplished much so
what I did instead was trying to earn
grouper
all and that'll get rid of these
timers appear and if it starts preparing
cure-all
hit the statues and it also remove all
the other tires living room
yes there's one for that we'll see after
this that that's a pretty good
appeal because now we don't have
anything away from hitting the stage
so this is where you have to
to really think you here this is a small
spaces morn column only that you can
actually use
and you gonna have to can struggle
through this
very thing you a mess they made so far i
mean circuit have a gap here
but getting another blue paper and
lawyers again
and will probably also into a situation
where we have to manage these
we were moves elsewhere
and basically just trying to make
matches and ways that'll
clear out space as
thing all alright so that's what we're
trying to set every other
will take that shower and no
now things change now we just basically
wanna
chip with the statues and
and your pick up these taxes
toppling chairs we have your own green
thing on top here so that's
not there's no real
sometimes appear both the same color
that'd be nice to
work those but for the most part we're
just gonna make big matches ever going
to send shock waves at the
got 27 moves left over pretty good
there's nothing really great their here
sir there
you know the home you could go after
this purple
here could take this out there because
the
trapped orders 2 o'clock so that's what
really fall but I'll
that's actually
a lot easier than then taking out these
at this point
American worry about that
right now I'm a sinister Negro green so
that I Q switch things up to hear that
also maybe
take out the cuts that Herbals looking a
lot better now
the forward to but now that that
open up for changes but just watchin
seem
see how we just that we picked up that
statue anyway so there really was no
memories we go our way for and the same
thing will happen on the side
you could try to plan you know based on
the trapdoor
how this is gonna go there but overall I
guess I your you'll pick it up
i'm looking for. shockwaves that this
warm
and women are available and is growing
green to
pick up this us that
right so we get that one
so we can take care of everything that
was was really hard
merely a twenty moved to get exposure
appear these guys
mmm Rick clear this column's here more
cream
Paul because you can see there's no
brings over here so these rings your
stay in place
and
once that's gone that actually makes it
a lot easier because these papers or
drop over here
so now we have three different color
sitting there
will just rooms have two grown
vanity with which ones were when
opportunity
right now green or purple are both good
there's one dream
year so there really will slide and
minerals
five-member stiffer but look who it
would
to you know
mess with were much
little bit stuck here this is kena
jumbled up
at the bottom
that'll do it
so it's definitely a challenging level
it's not easy by any stretch of the
imagination
but if you purchase in that way I am
you should be able to beat it I am I
want a consistory
but I'm you were the major things to
keep in mind there's
is the top part you need to open it up
and if you don't
I'm sure you pro if you're watching it
for the priority been stuck at the
bottom with nothing
are I mean you can literally sat there
and play out of 45 moves without a good
shot at getting at those taxes at the
top
what's the temp papers turn petrified
just small
get that many good opportunities to get
all the way up through the car
so this we go along with her for guide
and you should definitely read that
if you have any questions and comments
peace or like us on Facebook and I hope
this video helps the
you can get too low thanks